Dylan: Alright welcome back.
A little new idea for you here
and this one applies to learning
and most certainly would threaten to turn
our current educational
system on its head.
What's unclear is whether
it's good for America.
A California school called the
Khan Academy is reinventing
traditional teaching
by giving students lectures that they
can watch at home on their own time,
re-watch them if they'd like and
then having them do the homework
when they're in school in the classroom.
Salman: By removing the one size
fits all lecture from the classroom
and letting students have
a self pace lecture at home
and then when you go to the
classroom, letting them do work,
having the teacher walk
around, having the peers
actually be able to interact with
each other, these teachers have used
technology to humanize the classroom.
Dylan: Well the founder, Salman
Khan, started out by posting lessons
for his cousin on YouTube
and now the Khan Academy
has over a million
unique students per month
and boasts more than 2,000
tutorials covering everything
from basic addition and subtraction to
advanced calculus, physics and chemistry
and joining us now is Ben
Goldhirsh, the CEO of GOOD,
it's a company dedicated to moving
the world forward through its website,
magazine, videos and events.
He thought that Khan was one of
the breakout stars at this year's
Technology and Entertainment
and Design conference.
Before we get to all this
Khan Academy business Ben,
do you like it better when
we're on opposite coasts
or would you be comfortable if
I was to move out to California
to spend more time with you?
Ben: I would love to have you out here
Dylan, I think we do better in person.
Dylan: And do you feel
that you speak on behalf
of the entire southern
California community when
you welcome me into that universe?
Ben: The thoughtful ones.
Dylan: (laughs) Okay the thoughtful ones.
We won't get into how many thoughtful
ones there are but we will get into this.
Why did you decide to feature
this so prominently with GOOD?
Ben: For the past two years,
GOOD and University of Phoenix
have been focusing on solutions in this
education space and we haven't seen
anything like it and to contextualize the
findings for you, look at Los Angeles.
We have Teach for America, we have
City Year, we have KIPP Academy.
The best of the best of social innovators
but they're facing a serious problem.
600,000 students in LAUSD with
a 50 percent graduation rate.
That's terrifying and the
bottom line is the solutions
that we have on the ground, in my opinion,
aren't going to catch this problem.
We need a disruptive technology,
we need to really revolutionize
how we're tackling this.
Khan Academy is the first thing I've seen
that gives me confidence that
we're going to tackle it.
It's the most exciting thing I've
seen that we're doing to do this
so I'm pleased to bring it to your show,
I think we're going to dig
into a good conversation.
Dylan: Alright let's have at it.
The man behind the idea
joins us, Salman Khan.
Founder of the Khan Academy.
High praise for what you've got going
from our friend Ben down
there in southern California.
He's a thoughtful southern Californian,
is how he likes to refer to himself.
What have you found is the
biggest problem with this?
What is the greatest barrier, the
greatest resistance point to this?
Salman: Well I think that one,
it's such a radical change
to what traditionally
happens in a classroom.
If you're telling someone to
do homework in the classroom,
it's not called homework anymore.
But I think once teachers
and students get used to it,
it's kind of like they start to
think about they even did before.
Probably the biggest problem,
I wouldn't call it a problem
it's actually a great thing, in
the same classrooms we have a pilot
over here in northern California
where you have a 5th grade classroom,
this is their math curriculum, and
that same 5th grade classroom there are
some kids doing 3rd grade math and
there are some kids doing trigonometry
and the teacher needs to
feel comfortable with that.
But what's cool about it is that
they're getting a dashboard,
they see where everyone is and every
student can work at their own pace.
Dylan: If you were to look, Ben,
at the problem of having different,
same age, but at different places, right?
That's the whole thing with the
educational system is you got one kid
doing trigonometry and another
one who's trailing behind.
How do you see this, what did you see
about this, that you felt not only
addressed the drop out rate but addressed
the variability of how people learn?
Ben: I mean if you look at decreasing
budgets and increasing class sizes,
we need to solve the efficiency problem
and teacher's time is a limited amount.
So having this technology where they
can evaluate on a person-by-person basis
where their kids are at and they can
have their classroom time to work
with their kids who are at
different levels directly
so they can be taking the lectures
at home through Khan Academy,
that's a big solution
to a critical problem.
Dylan: Salman walk me through
very briefly how this works.
Let's say I've got a couple of kids,
they're in a traditional environment,
I'm intrigued by what your
saying, how would it work?
Salman: So every student
works at their own pace.
They literally do exercises at their
own pace, they start at one plus one
and they keep moving up all the way
through algebra or trigonometry,
however far they want to go.
If they have trouble with
anything the videos are there,
they can actually watch them
at home or in class time
and the teacher when they come to
class, they don't give lectures,
they don't grade homework,
they don't give exams.
They literally just get
a dashboard and they see
where every kid in the class
is and some kids may be ahead
and some kids might be behind.
And we actually see them flipping
around, some of the kids that were behind
race ahead later on and all the teacher
does is look at the kids who are stuck,
look at the kids where the video and
the software isn't enough for them
to get past that problem and then the
teacher just intervenes on those kids
or even better, gets one of the kids that
are already proficient on that module,
because they have all of the data
to actually tutor their peers.
So you can have a class where
everyone's working at their own pace.
Dylan: Got it, you say that
instead of penalizing failure
and rewarding test taking ability like
our current system does right now,
education should encourage failure and
experimentation but demand mastery.
Why do you think this model achieves that?
Salman: Well what we do is we force...
In a traditional model, I'll give you
some lectures, homework, lectures,
homework and then we have a snapshot
exam and regardless of whether you get
a 70 or 80 or 90 percent on that
exam, we move onto the next concept
and no one ever asks what was
that 10 percent you didn't know.
And so what we see happening in our
school system is by the time people
get to 8th or 9th grade, they're
taking algebra, they're smart kids,
they have a great algebra teacher,
but they're still flunking algebra
because they have that 10
percent gap from 5th grade math,
that 15 percent gap from 4th grade math.
So the way we're doing it is
we're actually teaching math
the way you would teach anything else.
If you learned to ride a bicycle
you would stay on that bicycle
until you master the bicycle
before you try a motorcycle
or a unicycle or anything more advanced.
So what we're doing is we're making sure
every kid has all of their gaps filled.
So they literally start at one plus
one equals two and they don't move on
until they have 100 percent mastery.
Dylan: Very quickly, Ben, what do you
see is the barrier to scaling this?
Ben: I think it's money, getting
Khan Academy the resources they need
to fill out their programming
and then getting school districts
to adopt a pretty innovative solution.
I think teachers are going to want this,
it's going to help them do their job
and I think given what we're facing, as
I said 50 percent of a 600,000 person
school district is looking to
not graduate from high school,
there aren't more jobs for
high school dropouts right now.
This must be adopted.
Dylan: Listen I wholeheartedly
agree and I thank you Ben Goldhirsh
as America's thoughtful southern
Californian for bringing that
to our attention and Salman it's
a true pleasure to meet you,
congratulations on what you've
achieved up to this point
and do let us know what we can
help you with in the future.
Check out all of it, of
course, on GOOD's website.